[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
this is live stream number 32
only 10 more to go before we discover
the answer to life the universe and
quite possibly
everything i'm not sure we have that
much time i'm not either i'm
just if that's what i'm getting at we
should accelerate the pace
that's not a bad idea yeah we could try
to get to it a little faster
all right um so i am sitting with dr
heather heing as always
and we are uh humming along here
2020 is continuing a pace and we
happen to be in portland in the center
of well let's just say
pretty much everything at the moment
it's the center of a lot of things
anyway
it does seem to be the center of a lot
of things so
should we start there let's start there
all right so
we don't know what you all know but you
have seen portland
trending on twitter if you're a twitter
person and you have recognized that
there is something afoot
so for something it's broken out into
the mainstream media as well
oh clearly clearly awareness of the
portland situation has
begun to reach the outer world
especially now that the jazz chop is
gone
right portland is uh is where it's
happening yeah so what we have
is a standoff that has continued for i
don't know something like
54 consecutive nights it very quickly
began to focus on
two federal buildings downtown
and um basically of late we have seen
federal agents not dressed in uniform
pulling people out of these riots into
what are described as
rented and therefore unmarked vehicles
taking them to an undisclosed location
which appears to be inside
one of the federal buildings and in
general the reports are that these
people are held for a time
and then they are released often without
charge
maybe always without charge um i did see
one instance in which somebody said they
were ultimately read their rights
um but in other cases they have not been
so in our last live stream
my conjecture was that
these were indications that the
rioters had triggered federal
provisions reserved for terrorism that
essentially suspend many aspects of the
constitution
and that in particular one should pay
attention to the ndaa of 2012 which had
two provisions in it
essentially allowing law enforcement to
pull people off of any street anytime
without explaining what they're doing
showing evidence against them
suspending habeas corpus rights and all
of that
in response to that live stream we got
a comment zach you want to show that
comment
all right as someone familiar with the
process i'd like to provide possible
insight
into federal pickups it's far more
likely that the agents
are monitoring video surveillance and
recordings of vandalism
and directing the pickup units who
surveil targets away from
uh crowds where i'm sorry i'm having
trouble reading it at this distance
i can't
yeah you pick it up it's far more likely
that agents are monitoring video
surveillance and recordings of vandalism
and directing the pickup units who
surveil targets away from crowds where
they pick them up to get positive id
so they can present the case to a
federal grand jury furthermore the fact
that they are taken into custody without
being read miranda is not
unconstitutional
miranda is only quite required prior to
interview not prior to detention
reads this comment so um the officer who
i have
described talking with in front of one
of these federal buildings on his last
day as a dhs
officer in portland contacted me
in response to that comment and said
that it was accurate now he doesn't know
anything about what's going on currently
because he's not stationed in
portland and he's not part of that
agency anymore but
his point is that when he was in on the
planning of what was taking place this
was one of the things that was being
contemplated and so i'd like to explain
what this means it does suggest that
more than likely the interpretation
that i had is at least not the one that
the federal government
is working from at at the on the ground
level which just to clarify means that
uh you said that what you were what we
were seeing
suggested that the ndaa had had been
implicitly at least invoked and
uh what we are currently coming to
understand suggested that may not be the
case yes now there is
slight ambiguity because when the obama
administration defended the provisions
of ndaa
they said that those provisions shocking
as they were did not actually provide
any new powers suggesting that they
already had those powers but
nonetheless there's a question about
whether or not a special terrorism
category has been triggered especially
in light of the fact that the president
has used that very term
this comment and the fact that a federal
officer who was stationed in portland
says that it is an accurate explanation
of what was
planned when he was here suggested
something else is afoot
which is imagine for a second that
somebody is stationed on the roof of one
of these buildings they are watching
crimes being committed for example
vandalism
or projectiles being launched something
like that they could then indicate to
people on the ground
that somebody was in the uh the midst of
committing crimes or had been observed
committing crimes but they wouldn't
necessarily know who that person
is because of course people are dressed
with masks and other things that obscure
their identity
so a team on the ground would collect
individuals take them to a cell where
their
identity was would be ascertained by
some mechanism i don't know what it
would be
but let's say facial recognition
or fingerprints or i don't know what it
is
but nonetheless that that would then be
used to
uh to get a grand jury a federal grand
jury to indict which is apparently a
very different process than takes place
when crimes are prosecuted locally now
i must tell you there's a lot of this
that disturbs me on the other hand what
i think is missing from the portland
story
is the fact that there is no good
solution that we've been left
in a terrible bind by the
local city officials remember our mayor
mayor wheeler is also our police
commissioner so he is in a position to
play
the george bridges role here in portland
and to frustrate the local police so
that they do not act
this is what we have seen for close to
two months now
with attacks on federal buildings that
are obviously
quite illegal that are dealt with
basically by an appeasement here locally
now because the protesters have chosen
federal buildings
there's a whole second layer which is to
say the federal government is not
hamstrung by mayor wheeler so there is a
division between what the local police
are doing which is to say very little
because they can't and what the federal
police are doing which is to say
they are now ratcheting up some sort of
approach to protect these buildings
now if you're disturbed by the federal
approach you need to ask yourself some
questions which is
why have the protesters chosen these
buildings why would they choose federal
buildings
in part the answer is surely because
they want a federal crackdown
why do they want a federal crackdown
because they're very interested in
portraying
this as some sort of egregious
governmental
overreach when in fact those of us who
live in portland
know that we have a problem we have
people being violent consistently over
many nights
who are facing uh very few restrictions
on their behavior and it makes us wonder
whether or not
violence against us will be tolerated in
the same way
now if i can just add one final thing
before we discuss this
i want you to run a thought experiment
let's imagine for a second
that i personally just me became
agitated about governmental corruption
which i am
and let's suppose i decided to do the
same thing to these federal buildings
that these protesters are doing
what do you think would happen to me i
think i'd be arrested
that's what i think and what's more you
can run the same experiment these
protests happen every night
hundreds to thousands of people show up
and
um you can just ask the question suppose
i were to approach the buildings during
the day
don't you think it's likely i would be
arrested for attacking these buildings i
feel certain of it
i feel certain i wouldn't get away with
it which tells you that there's
something
about these crowds of individuals
that are not triggering the same
response to law breaking as i would
and initially you could argue that this
has something to do with the number of
people that basically
a proper law enforcement response was
not easy to manage
in the early days but that surely is not
the case months down the road
right there certainly there are tactics
there are things we do when lots of
people decide to break the law together
even if they initially overwhelm the
system
once you realize that that's happening
you bring in more resources from
elsewhere if need be
you come up with tactics and you enforce
the law so
the result of this thought experiment i
think is that it is
what the people attacking these
buildings are saying what they represent
that is causing them to be allowed to
violate the law
and others of us who might have very
legitimate complaints about the way the
federal government runs
would not be given the same leeway i
think this paints a very difficult
puzzle and what i would like to know
from
people who see this as somehow a
positive
uh thing is what exactly it is that they
are envisioning there's no
demand that could be met here are should
the
protesters be allowed to burn down
federal buildings in the heart of
portland is that what is being said
because the protesters say
look you know and they spray paint this
on the buildings they say
property damage is not violence so
basically their sense is that they have
a right to attack these buildings
the city government tacitly agrees with
that the federal government disagrees it
is its obligation to disagree
and the people of the city of portland
are caught in the middle
you have anything on this topic that you
want to add
yeah i mean there's a lot to say uh one
thing that
i know just a little bit about that i'm
not sure that i want to add to your
to you the story here is that apparently
i think it's city commissioner hardesty
uh
who is as a leftist as they get
on the i think it's i think it's the
portland city council i'm not totally
sure of what her position
is um has been decrying
how um ineffective wheeler has been
uh basically arguing that he has
overseen this brutal police force that
has been hurting people
and so is trying to wrest control of the
police force away from him
and what she has in her position at the
moment somehow is
uh control over the portland police
bureau
and a couple of days ago the portland
police bureau i didn't prepare any of
this so i don't i don't have all of my
details here but um
the portland police bureau that has 18
or 20
sites around the city as you would
expect they would put out a statement
saying
uh not now not ever will we allow
staging by either portland city police
or the federal officers
uh to work from where we are now the
idea that
uh the two essential city services
um our a overseen by two different um
officials is
is a little surprising to me you know
why if um
the mayor is the police commissioner why
isn't he also in control of
of the the firemen so you meant fire
bureau or police bureau
wheeler is control of the police yep but
you said why isn't he in control of fire
right and so it's the fire bureau that
has forbidden the
shared access of the federal officers
but also by the police
this this this is the point that the the
local fire
department has declared itself unwilling
to and has said that it never has
allowed
staging tactics strategy anything by
local police
also federal officers but just put that
aside for the moment yeah
it is it is surprising right that
there should be this kind of wrestling
near the top of city government
and the argument appears to be that
wheeler who was clearly spineless and
incompetent and
unwilling to keep his people safe
is being it's being argued that he
actually
is too far to the right somehow like he
he's he's too much a law and order guy
this guy who's let downtown portland
uh be be in flames
um have tremendous vandalism etc
and he is he is being marched to anarchy
by the phony accusation of being
authoritarian and and this is this is
making it ever less
likely that he will actually step up and
do anything which is of course part of
why
we have federal officers here in the
first place because it's it's clear to
outsiders and to most insiders
of the city um that not that this is not
going to end well
at in its current direction and wheeler
has said of the federal
uh law enforcement uh
uh staff that that he wants them to
leave
and that to the extent that they have an
obligation to defend these buildings he
says fine
go inside them and defend them from
there which is obviously
preposterous i mean for one thing
incendiary devices have been launched
into these buildings
so um the abdication of responsibility
at the city level
has created a federal problem and now it
is being portrayed
as if the federal problem isn't you know
the federal response is inherently an
overreach you know it may be an
overreach but
it that it would be inherent that it was
an overreach when the local authorities
are simply not enforcing the law
right so what do we say about this uh
this image that i think is spread far
and wide now
of a navy veteran wearing uh navy vet
garb
right um which he says he did
intentionally so that
uh in the hopes that he would get
interaction
uh you know decent human interaction
from the officers whom he was facing
uh whom we see standing tall and proud
and alone
and being beaten on by police until he
finally turns around and
reports later that he is that he is
somewhat damaged as you would expect he
would be
yeah um we know something you know we
have some thoughts about what's going on
you want to start
well i would just say that it raises a
question i mean it's
first of all a very dramatic piece of
footage that somebody quite dramatic
is standing there and withstanding a
physical attack that's
quite powerful but there's also a
question about you know what was the
interaction that resulted
in that attack and um
we've heard uh we've heard that
there had been regular announcements for
you know many minutes up to an hour
beforehand
by and i don't know if it was the police
the federal officers to clear the area
to get out of the area
they were going to start using if it was
if they said tear gas it was federal
officers because local police aren't
allowed to
uh and that that that looks
true to me uh in part because the scene
is otherwise empty
uh in the scene that is these scenes
that we're seeing from that particular
part of
portland at those times of night for the
last consecutive whatever you said 54
days
um is always chaotic with lots of people
running uh
back and forth and and everywhere and so
um this
this looks to have been a scene that had
been cleared and was
attempted to be being cleared and you
know that doesn't
that presumably doesn't justify a
beating
but it also doesn't make uh that that
man
an innocent as he is portraying himself
and this i mean this
this is the thing is how much of what we
are hearing
is pr and how would we know like that
that's the question
always we certainly experience this at
evergreen when we started to see the pr
machine you know get tripped into gear
and start um making actions
that they knew would play well with some
part of the outside world
yeah so obviously a tall
strong independent man in
navy where patriot patriot who is being
beaten on
this looks like the authoritarian
madness that we are being told is rife
in every police department across the
country
but i don't think that's what we were
actually well and you have to play it
through
so let's imagine that you decided to
precipitate an event and so the police
say
clear out we're about to uh to come
through the area
you approach them instead you have some
interaction where you refuse to go
now might be that what they should have
done is handcuffed him and dragged him
off i don't but i don't
we don't know the situation because what
we have is exactly what fell in the
frame
we don't have the context that happened
before we don't have the contents of the
interaction between him and the officers
and so the point is yeah that looks
um that looks bad we have two we have
two types of media
and this that story that we've all now
seen at least pieces of plays really
well with cnn
and with npr and with msnbc and some
alternative story will play really well
with fox
and you know fox mostly um you know and
and a lot of minor outlets that don't
have as much play
but basically all of these outlets fall
prey
to just reporting on the narrative that
they always already agree with
all right that's that's what they do so
we actually have some
uh footage that will illustrate your
point okay so
zach do you want to show the um
first the uh the the attack on the
building
yeah so you know frame this for us this
is a few nights ago last night something
important
in the last two nights it may even be
last night and you'll see uh
they've approached the building they've
torn down the
fence and they're now approaching the
building and they've set off an
explosion
presumably that's from a large
firecracker or something but these
firecrackers are they're explosives
that's
that's one of the federal buildings
that's one of the the two federal
buildings that are under
nightly attack um okay so you see that
can you uh
do the one with the officer now
uh i believe so okay this is
a federal officer being physically
attacked
by rioters um
gets up the perpetrators get away
okay so that's a physical attack and
mind you that physical attack bad as it
is
doesn't really compare to the danger of
people using
slingshots to launch bbs at these
officers right i mean imagine what a bb
coming from a splint slingshot will do
to somebody's head
um if it hits them so anyway these these
people are playing with very dangerous
tactics and
with weapons many of which sound like
they're not very serious
firecracker slingshot but they are very
serious
okay but then take those two things on
the one side
now play the clip
[Music]
this is i believe last night
you can see there's some installation
art
feds out of fed goons out of pediatrics
out of pdx projected on the building got
people holding up their cell phones with
the flashlight on as if they were
holding up their lighters
singing we shall overcome now what's
going on here
first of all mothers have shown up
uh to defend the rioters
a group of people who say we are mothers
they are muslims they appear to be
mothers
fathers apparently or people who appear
to be fathers showed up
to join the fight and so what we have
is an allusion to past protests very
honorable protests protests against the
vietnam war for example
that are playing out in the midst of a
violent
and concerted attack on federal officers
and federal buildings
so the point is the edit tells you which
of these things you're going to see
and therefore how you're going to feel
about it is fascism coming to portland
or uh is the federal response the
natural thing that has to happen
when the local authorities have
abdicated responsibility
right it's two stories that uh simply
cannot be made to reconcile
it plays out a little bit in uh in
across temporal
lines right the uh the more peaceful
protests happen before dark and the
violence really ramps up after dark
so you know there is there is the
possibility that someone wandering in
at one time or the other would actually
not be aware of the other on the other
hand at this point
given what we know is happening every
single night in portland every single
night after dark into into the wee hours
you know
this time of year it gets dark pretty
late um
how how could you be that confused
about this being a totally honorable and
peaceful protest
it's it can't be it can't be at this
point
so i think the at this point is crucial
and i i was um
talking to eric last night and thinking
about some things and we were going back
through some of the
prior protests that have occurred
especially in this part of the world
and i was thinking in particular about
occupy and initially you and i were very
enthusiastic about occupy because it
seemed like finally this was something
new and different that was protesting
things that needed to be protested like
the tarp program too big to fail the
obvious catastrophe of credit default
swaps and
leveraging and all of this and
the thing was there was the sense that
we hadn't seen
anything progressive in
decades maybe at all in our lifetime and
suddenly there was motion where
suddenly we were we were protesting the
things that needed protesting
and the problem is inside it then became
clear that it went from a protest
against
thing it was a coherent protest to an
anarchist protest
and i tried to persuade i mean i wrote a
couple of articles in fact
trying to persuade them that anarchism
was an answer to nothing and that they
needed to get back on track which of
course didn't work
but my point is there are those who are
just simply waiting for anything that
doesn't look like
what they've experienced and to the
extent that the antifa
riots are portraying themselves as
progressive there are a lot of people
who aren't paying close attention who
think okay finally
right we're in the streets you know
protesting for the right thing
when in fact they're protesting for the
wrong thing they're protesting for
the uninvention of all of the uh the
liberal
principles on which the nation was
founded and to which
we were headed so well and you and you
saw more than i did
even in occupy as as you watched it
unravel from the inside
uh a specific rejection of the idea of
leadership
right a specific rejection of the idea
that
individuals should be in position
of of leadership or able to
not necessarily dictate but have the
role of being able to help
run help facilitate uh situations and
groups of people
such that decisions could be made the
idea of hierarchy
was its self-anathema right and so this
this struck both of us as delusional
right
it is it is this utopian vision that has
no
chance of actually happening we can do
better we can certainly do better than
what evolution has handed us
and uh we have been we have lived in
much more hierarchical ways in the past
with much more rigid roles
around lots of things like race and like
sex than we need to
but the idea that hierarchy is itself
either we are either capable of getting
rid of it
or it is worthy of of being gotten rid
of
both of those ideas are are batshit
crazy
that makes no sense at all and it tells
you right there
that the movement um has no chance of
success
in the way that it's claiming it wants
success
and also one of the ways that it works
tactically
is it makes it very much harder to chase
it down
because because who do you go after and
you know one person says
all cops are bastards and another person
says defund the police another one says
abolish the police another one says
we don't want any policing at all and
you go back to the first one they said
well i never said that that's not my
position and i'm antifa and you know
maybe they aren't
maybe maybe they're they're playing at
it and so
the lack of leadership is not only uh in
insane
if you try to scale that up at a
societal level but it is actually also
incredibly effective at a tactical level
with regard to street level riots
yeah it runs through your fingers as you
try to pin down what it is that we're
even talking about
so this is this is exactly my concern
is that you've got a huge fraction of
the energy here
in 2020 on the nominal left
is well got to get rid of trump here's a
powerful movement that says it's liberal
and um you know and look they're singing
we shall overcome
right that looks pretty good if it says
it's liberal it must be liberal if it
says it's anti-racist must be
anti-racist if they sing those songs
they must be on our side because the
people who used to sing those songs made
sense
it's really easy to sing songs it is
although
there's too little of it i mean what
song are we saying right this i mean of
course we're going to
you know so singing a song is easier to
fake than humor
yeah right we at the point that they
start faking
humor is then we're really doomed right
i think
but you know we don't we don't see that
really happening because as you know as
you and matt tayyip pointed out and as
we've been pointing out for years this
is
this is humorless yeah it's a humorous
movement it is a humorless movement
um but the problem is the intersection
with the
election is setting us up for disaster
because so many people
i mean i hear it all the time people say
well you know when biden gets in this
will die down
no the the biden camp is actually
partnering with it they're picking up
the energy from this movement
now either you think the biden camp is
going to betray the movement after the
election
in which case i would say small disaster
or they're not going to betray the
movement after the election and we're
going to start
making policy based on this absurd
reinterpretation of reality
and we're going to have an absolute
catastrophe on our hands
so maybe maybe that's a good segue to
talk um
well first to answer a question that i
got asked on twitter that was directed
at both of us and then to talk about
some of the other places
we're seeing the manifestations of this
which we've talked about in many
previous episodes but the idea that
this movement is what we're seeing on
the streets and the riots in a few
choice u.s cities at this point no no
it's it's everywhere and it doesn't look
like
what's going on on the streets of
portland everywhere far from it
it's much more white collar in gentile
most places and that's the way it's
going to sneak in on you and and and get
you
uh yeah we've talked about white
fragility before we've talked about
what's happening in arts
and uh we're gonna talk a little bit
here about what's happening in academia
still and again
and god help us always you know i hope
not
but so i was asked on twitter
this guy begins by saying a big fan love
what you guys are doing
um but i do want to ask you do you think
that living in portland
this is a quote from him do you think
that living in portland which seems like
ground zero for the woke volusion
is coloring y'all's hopes and fears for
the future for example i live in a small
town in virginia
we thank god haven't had 50 nights of
rioting in a row
curious if you think that the northwest
violence will inevitably spread virally
throughout the country or if it's a big
city phenomenon
and you know my one of my first
responses to that and we should talk
about it is
as we've been saying for decades but
publicly since evergreen blew up what
happens on campus doesn't stay on campus
guys
it it was never going to and so this is
a direct
a direct result of what's been going on
on campus
and the point of this is that it's going
to spread and it is spreading and we see
the media captured and uh
you know arts organizations increasingly
captured in higher ed
and k12 schools and increasingly the
courts and
you know it's capture one by one by one
so
it is it is quite possible that our lens
is
clouded that we we are seeing this on
the other hand
actually you know we live in a part of
portland where we don't have to run into
this at all
we don't we don't see it uh unless we
choose to to go to it and
figure out what we can see with our own
eyes as opposed to what's been filtered
by other people
so um you know that's that's also a
filter that people are saying oh my god
are you you're important are you safe
yeah you know it's it's a it's a very
it's a few
very limited very minor very
horrifying vary at risk of becoming
giant
uh sets of movements that are happening
in both downtown and
eastern portland yeah um
i think you know we should probably at
some point catalog
the misunderstandings that we think
people were talking to
are having one of them is that this is
about
symbolic stuff this is very definitely
about
power over material things ultimately
this results in a transfer of material
things through mechanisms
that are not
legitimate but nonetheless the
horizontal nature of this whole movement
means that it is now infused in every
place that can make a judgment
and so you know hiring firing
the courts every place that can make a
judgment there is now an expectation
that these things will go
in a particular direction yep and you
know it can't work it's a very
short-term strategy but will it
ultimately
um get to you it will get to you and you
know who's telling you that
the people who said that it was going to
escape you know
the university system back when
evergreen was
the you know the type specimen so um
i i think it's just certain that if
something does not
turn the tide that this will ultimately
wash over everything and it will of
course
render the us a feeble power which will
create a power vacuum
and then we'll find out what dynamics
are really going to govern our lives
yeah okay so should we talk a little bit
about the
the stupid that's coming out of medical
academia and other academia that sounds
like fun yeah it's always fun
okay zach uh put this up if you would
sweetie
um australian doctors push renaming
adam's apple the achilles tendon and
other misogynistic terms
this is for real this is not in the
onion or whatever australia's version of
the onion is i can't remember at the
moment
um i mean these things really speak for
themselves but
so remember achilles oh my god oh my god
so
there are a lot of body parts that are
named for the people who
just who were the first people in
western science to discover them
and of course until very recently that
was mostly limited to you know landed
white men
and okay fine
what are we doing and the adam's apple
and the achilles tendon
these aren't even real people guys like
this is mythology
right this is mythology and achilles was
a know
a great warrior i don't know maybe he
was real but
he got sick and the adam's apple the
adam's apple is an ugly lump
and the achilles tendonitis it's only my
new
famous vulnerability we're gonna rename
one of the parts that's actually only in
only in men so uh
i i don't even have much more on that
it's just so
absurd and no here's the what's more i
mean
it's funny but it's so unfunny because
the answer is people are not
extrapolating right this is the level of
thinking of the people who tell you they
know what we're supposed to do
next yeah right this is the level of
thinking right
and like and the kind of language they
use is often
decolonize decolonize our language and
in fact
uh the next example is is that
too grammar um oh boy
rutgers english department to
de-emphasize traditional grammar quote
in solidarity with black lives matter
yeah please um i just read the headline
of what what you guys can now see
um the chair of the rutgers english
department sent out an email announcing
plans to
decolonize again english by in part
focusing less on grammar quote
uh this approach from the department of
english at rutgers emailed to
her people this approach challenges the
familiar dogma that writing instruction
should limit emphasis on grammar and
sentence level issues so as to not put
students from multilingual non-standard
academic english backgrounds at a
disadvantage
so we can still man this briefly and say
i have actually taught with faculty
who were really good at grammar level
correction and
didn't weren't really able to see the
bigger
you know why do we write in the first
place we don't write to have perfect
grammar we write in order to say
something
right so a focus entirely on grammar is
misguided
and will kill the spirit and creativity
of the
best students and you know actually all
students i think
and so um should writing instruction
be focused also on content and big ideas
and not exclusively on copy editing but
also on
editing and actual content of course it
should
and too many writing teachers don't do
that i don't know if it's because they
can't or because they're lazy
or because they honestly think that
grammar is the end-all and be-all
but the idea that grammar
shall that everyone shall not be held to
the standards
of of of grammar including this isn't
just for undergraduate papers they're
suggesting this for
dissertations for phd level
dissertations
this is the soft bigotry of low
expectations this that is exactly what
this is
trying to help people help help people
by assuring them that they won't be held
to standards
that's not helping them that's not
helping them in any way it's
beyond the soft bigotry of low expo it
is because yeah because it's actually a
direct
insult because the obviously correct
thing
is that these things are readily
learnable and we've done a terrible job
of democratizing the tools to do it and
the right thing to do is to democratize
those tools
to pretend that there is something
within certain populations that puts
correct grammar out of reach is an
insane
insult i mean it's it's robin d'angelo
all over again like
this this department chair is either so
confused and scared
by the uh inaccurately named black lives
matter movement
or is actually personally a racist and
really believes uh
that people from backgrounds that aren't
like hers can't do very well
it's one of those two things i think
like what are the other possibilities on
the table
this is it but the other thing which i
never see anybody say
is all right or actually i occasionally
see people say this now
if you institute these standards you are
so
hobbling us nationally that you are
guaranteeing we lose our position going
forward
right if our phds
cannot speak with precision because
nobody has required it of them
then they will not speak with precision
what will happen to the quality of
discourse if people
who are responsible for discourse do not
do it with precision
well then our thinking will degrade
right what happens in a school of
engineering when you decide that logic
and
math are white supremacist well you
stopped doing logic and math well what
happens
sooner or later the bridges start
falling down how long do you imagine we
can impose
this nonsense on all of the systems that
actually do make things
work and not have them come apart and
it's totally consistent with the idea
that hierarchy is itself
racist or sexist or whatever ist you
want to choose right the idea
if the idea of hierarchy is itself a
problem then you can't have better and
worse
you you can't actually have assessment
of quality because quality itself if
hierarchy doesn't exist then quality
doesn't exist
yeah right there there is there is no
ranking possible
on any level which is a conflation
of you know equal under the law
with i every single individual is
identically capable of all things which
no one in their right mind would claim
yeah every single individual is not
equal and equally capable of all things
even if we manage to completely equalize
all opportunity from moment for moment
one we
we vary that's that is the result of
evolution
so one way to think about this is the
level of insanity of the claims that are
now
regularly surfacing the level of
insanity is a
direct measure of the strength of the
underlying game theory of this movement
in other words the feebleness of the
argument
floats on the fact that it is very
difficult to oppose it without paying
a price right and it is that thing so
it's this move
where the idea is um
here is a thing and you have to say it
and if you resist
then you are the thing that is being
alleged so if you say
um for example that you know
logic is not uh a white
trait then you are engaged in
anti-black racism so the point is people
then
say that it is a white trait
doing all kinds of harm in the process
but they do that and what happens is
they get an immediate
it's it's addiction right it's this
thing
how do you get addicted to your phone
somebody has figured out how to trigger
these little releases of dopamine and
they get you coming back for more
so if you feel a threat and then
somebody is capable of removing that
threat
you may figure out how to do the thing
that keeps getting the threat to back
off and what are you doing you're
becoming an accomplice to the movement
that's how you're getting the threat to
back off
but of course it's utterly free to make
a threat
it's it's in this context it is free to
make a threat it is
free to attack a federal building
there's all kinds of things
that have become free and so what i
think
we're watching day in and day out at all
sorts of levels
is people serving their own immediate
interests motivated by
fear and emboldening the movement that
is creating the fear
it you know it's it's the the the child
who sends the adults into the cornfield
um and the thing is eventually you have
to confront the child because there's no
there's no solution that comes from
everybody you know saying what the child
wants you to say and
that's what we're looking at yeah no it
feels
it feels ever more juvenile but this
these aren't these aren't reasonable
children
you know man this this is a topic for
many many many of their conversations as
you know as
as we have had as we have raised our own
children and written about childhood and
what childhood
is and how it is that you make strong
and resilient and awesome
and humor-filled and and loving children
into adults uh you do not cater to every
whim
and you do not run scared when they
throw a tantrum
you don't cave to tantrums ever and if
what you do is you say don't do that or
all x
and they keep doing it and you don't do
x
they do it more of course they do that
is basic human psychology of course they
do more of it and that is exactly what
we're seeing on our streets it's exactly
what we're seeing
in boardrooms what we're seeing in
colleges it's what we're seeing
every place this is really badly raised
children in the bodies of adults
uh acting like maybe they were taught to
act by their parents who didn't know how
to parent and never said no
and you know imagine that that's all
taking place on a ship and what they're
doing is they're getting
us to uh allow them to take apart the
ship on which we all depend
including them you didn't just invoke a
canoe did you
wow no okay canoe is not a ship it's a
boat but it's not a ship i looked it up
i was just i was confused about the
the sudden input of ship into the
conversation
you know it's funny because i actually
really like canoes as a vessel but i
agree with you there is a certain amount
of trauma around the idea of canoes for
us at the moment
yeah okay should we talk about racism in
the great outdoors
what could possibly go wrong what could
possibly go wrong
oh boy this is just i mean this is an
episode of just a lot of ridiculous
um yeah now you can show this sack
uh oregon's natural spaces feel off
limits to black people we are told this
is
uh this is opb's this is oregon public
broadcasting oregon's
npr station uh we're being told that
parks and
trail heads are slowly reopening as they
as they should be we've got an extended
anecdote from someone a black woman who
uh explains that while she was excited
initially when she moved to
portland area to start going outside
when she did go she found that she was
one of very few black people on the
trails
and um and then the logical leap felt
that that was due to racism and that she
was experiencing racism from all the
non-black people that she saw
um there is a quote in this article i
don't know exactly where it is on the
page right now
uh quote recent data from the oregon
parks and recreation department shows
black people are under
underrepresented as visitors to state
parks they make up 2.2 percent of
oregon's population
and 0.9 percent of daily visitors and
1.9 of overnight visitors to parks
so it's a really white state
whole pacific northwest is really really
really white right 2.2 percent of the
population is black that's about 1 in
50.
therefore even if there was exact
representation
due to race on the trails only one in 50
people you'd see would be black
you'd still feel like you were rare
because
you are and that may be due to other
issues that might need addressing
but that has nothing to do with whether
or not the trails don't have enough
black people on them
overnight visitors 1.9 versus 2.2 total
that doesn't look far off at all 0.9 of
daily visitors
we don't know if that's actually not
representative there are no statistics
here
and even if it were what is it that the
claim is
that is keeping people of color black
people
off the trails well i i read as far into
this article as i could get myself to
read
um and the person and i you know i don't
want to belittle her perspective
for one thing it may be accurate but
what she says is that it's the
looks that she gets from people on the
trails
the problem is we're now in the
evergreen paradigm which is
okay that claim in and of itself
could mean that you're getting looks
that mean something or it could mean
that you're getting looks but you're
misinterpreting them or it could be that
you're not getting looks and you're
imagining it
we have no way of knowing you would have
to test this somehow
but the thing that's getting me is i
don't know where it is somewhere in one
of our early
live streams i used this exact example
to prove that the fact of a disparity in
representation
does not mean that it's racism right you
will find
blacks underrepresented in recreational
cycling for example
yes is i've worked in a bike shop is
that because bike shops are in some way
reluctant to sell bikes to black people
no bike shops are inhabited by liberals
who probably if anything would feel
extra good about doing so so it's not
the bike shops
i don't think i've never seen any
evidence that a bike lane was racist
i just it's very hard to see
where the bias would be you realize that
you are now introducing hypotheses into
the world
that some people will take and run with
or bike with or
something but look let's be honest about
this and let's
steal man the position i actually do
think there's racism
somewhere in these biases right by which
biases the biases that we would see
racially on trails or bike lanes or
something right
like the racism is way way way way
upstream okay it has to do with
differential access
in other words why do you and i end up
on trails right we came from families
who did this where did the families get
this idea well they had
a was in the culture of those families
that you know
they neither of them came from privilege
but there was a certain amount of
access there was a certain amount of
expectation and the point is different
people end up valuing different things
now
i think it'd be great if people spent
more time outdoors irrespective of who
they were
right i think we need more outdoor space
in order to make that better right so
that you could actually get away from
people given the
huge population of the planet but the
fact that there may be some differential
access
issue that has kept some populations
farther away from trails does not mean
that there's anything about those modern
day trails
that is in any way less accessible right
so
culture is the clear conspicuous likely
place that some sort of bias would live
not at the trailhead right and it's also
true and this is
also a point that we've made multiple
times before
that when you get looks that don't seem
right and that aren't the
looks that you were hoping for expecting
you can think of yourself and what
demographic markers you have and imagine
that it is due to the ones that are most
likely
to have bias against them in the
population
and sometimes that will be true you know
sometimes i get looks
uh or comments or yelled at or whatever
and it is because i'm a woman
and the dude yelling is is a dude and
that is what it is and sometimes it's
not
and with regard to sexism you could tell
in part when it is because of the nature
of the comments
and sometimes you can't tell for sure at
all and with race
obviously you could tell in the context
of some comments but
i don't boy you know that's not what's
happening on the trails
like you know she and she doesn't say
that they're you know no one is making
explicitly racist comments to this woman
and her son on the trails
but um you know is she getting looks of
surprise shock disappointment
interest pleasure you know any number of
things
that might also be mixed mixed with or
you know causally related to
not i don't think you belong here but i
didn't
expect to see you because actually you
know no one's doing this math explicitly
but one in 50 people
are black in oregon and frankly fewer
than that tend to end up
on the trails yeah and that has nothing
to do
with therefore i don't want you on the
trails so i experienced this a little
bit in a different place and i just want
to talk about
i think how you deal with this
responsibly when you don't know what
you're up against okay
when my last name gets invoked i often
see something flash across the eyes of
somebody that i'm interacting with right
and it you know i i'm betting that some
fraction of the time it's oh
jewish right now sometimes that might be
an anti-semite
very rarely i would imagine right but
the point is there's no
content in just the flicker of somebody
has recognized something that you can
interpret with any sort of certainty
right so you have to file it
agnostically what was that i don't know
and i assume it's nothing and even if it
was some sort of mild anti-semitism or
suspicion or something that somebody
harbors a what happens next
is the interaction likely overwhelms
whatever prejudice they walked into it
with and you know we know this we know
that what
addresses prejudice successfully is
interaction
and so prejudice i'm not sure we
we're using the words exactly
identically but let's establish first
how we're using them before
i say this prejudice can be due to
bigotry or due to ignorance
these are two different sources so you
know a prejudice in which
uh someone is walking into an
interaction finds out that your ex
and goes i don't know about that
could be due to actual bigotry i think
you are less i have reason to think you
are less because your ex
or i just have no exposure to you and i
have no idea and therefore i kind of
don't know what to do
yeah i wonder and maybe maybe you don't
want to i didn't
ask you in advance if you want to say
something about
the first time you met my grandfather
yeah sure let me just say prejudice-wise
all i'm saying i'm just
going as literal as possible just some
sort of prejudgment some sort of
assumption
about what i will be that doesn't come
from any information so i think then
prejudice can
be due either to bigotry um or to
ignorance yep
and um those two things are being
conflated across the board in the
current movement
right you know black lives matter uh and
white fragility
and how to be an anti-racist and all of
these things
are imagining that um you know i
i have made the claim many times and i
firmly believe that the very few
americans are actually racist
but i think that a fair number are
somewhat ignorant and i think
a number of people who are falling prey
to this oh my god i'm going to genuflect
because i'm scared that i'm i'm a racist
so i must be a racist
i think most people are not actually
racist but they're naive they're
ignorant they don't have experience of
the world over the cultures of other
people
and uh and that ignorance is actually so
so so different from real bigotry and
the completion of those two is is
is demonic it's awful it is demonic
because for one thing
a will for willful ignorance might be
one thing
but just simple ignorance the fact is a
exposure erases it yeah
and b for many of us i mean i've said
many times i have no doubt that i am
ignorant
on every axis that i am not a
participant i will always be somewhat
ignorant of what it is like to be gay to
be a woman to be black
because i'm not any of these things
however i'm interested in all of those
fronts to reduce that ignorance as much
as possible
right yeah what else can i do so you
know do you really want to
you know persecute somebody that they're
for being racist
on the basis of ignorance that they're
actively trying to address
no that would be absurd and yet that's
where we are somehow
um so yeah your grandfather um you know
there was definitely
a flash of recognition
that he was dealing with a jewish person
clearly he didn't
have a lot of exposure um so i think you
need to set it up a little bit he
he had he this is northeastern iowa
uh throughout my father's and my
father's siblings uh growing up
they were on a farm uh and
and he had spent some time traveling
around north dakota and some of the
other
northern midwestern states but he was
basically he was a he was a
german catholic um he didn't immigrate
but
uh boy i don't actually remember i think
either he was either
second or third generation um immigrant
uh and just had traveled a fair bit
within
northern white north america uh is all
and um you were almost certainly the
first jewish person that he met
at the point that i brought um you and
you know i think my dad and you and i
all went out there my dad had flown out
uh to chicago and we'd all driven out to
iowa to see him for maybe a thanksgiving
or something yeah yeah
yeah i mean so this would have been the
90s sometimes it's not too much to say
except that there was definitely a
palpable
tension about something which i i took
to be about that
and it didn't persist because
interaction
doesn't allow it to persist because you
know i remember it more explicitly than
this
oh you do yeah and you know maybe maybe
i'm wrong maybe maybe my memory is wrong
um but i remember him actually uh
responding to being introduced to you by
me
with an epithet that he didn't think was
wrong
i believe that he said jew boy he did i
remember that i had this immediate
reaction i think i even like put out my
hands like ah
great like what and you know i never i'd
never spent a whole lot of time with him
i didn't know him very very well but um
uh and you as i remember it sort of put
your hands out to me and said no
not a big deal let's talk and you that
the two of
you as i remember it then had a
conversation
for i don't know if it was 20 minutes or
two hours but something
between those two things uh in which you
didn't talk about judaism and you didn't
talk about jewishness
but you engaged with each other as human
beings
and um and he wasn't
less ignorant of judaism as a result
right because that's not what you're
about and it's not what he
it's not what you were talking about but
what he did know at the end of it was
that you were
a you know deep rich compassionate
uh human being with you know all of
these
all of these insights and capabilities
that he would hope for
in you know the partner of his
granddaughter and
uh that identifying anyone uh
by a word that is singular and
reductive is not the way to engage
people
yeah um and it actually
brings back up this question about the
uh the proposal was it duke that is
changing its grammar
uh oh well yeah um
here's my concern is that actually
this language thing might actually be
about something
[Laughter]
and that you don't say yeah i do say
yeah um i mean watch this i'm even going
to use language in order to explain my
point you'll see how it works
you'll catch right on i'm sure but
the thing is if you don't have imagine
that you're
faced with uh somebody who has a
prejudice
uh against you but doesn't share
language right
it's very hard to overcome that
prejudice because you can't deliver
evidence that actually tells them that
actually you're of like mind
about values or something like that
assuming that's the case
um but then we can extend this which is
if you share no language you have very
few tools with which to do this they
might see you engage in behavior that is
inconsistent with their prejudice but
the chances of that are pretty low
because it requires circumstances to
bring it out
um but my point would be the better
the language that you share the more
tools you have
to erode those prejudices and to fill in
the ignorance with
information and to the extent that what
we are going to do
is take the rules away from
grammar for example in order not to
ostensibly disadvantage anybody what
we're also doing is taking away the
expectation
of a shared paradigm in which you can
reach somebody and if i would if i can
remind people
of the story that i told about living in
jamaica
the thing about the jamaican kids who
were so fascinated by me because i came
from a different world but i took them
seriously
i would answer their questions for
example they had lots of scientific
questions they wanted answered
was they spoke two languages they spoke
patois which i didn't speak
well i understood some but i struggle
with patois it's very difficult
but they because television and school
takes place in the queen's english as it
were
speak my language perfectly which means
there was no trouble connecting with
them
right because they could step into this
idiom in which we could exchange
information and so
i'm not in some sense i do think we
might have to step into a world where we
actually
all do have a language so that we are
not tripping over
the border between english and chinese
for example when
you know military matters are at stake
you know i think we might actually need
to have the ultimate tool to protect
planet earth from
our de facto sectarian differences
but that doesn't mean you can't retain
the languages in which we prefer to
speak to each other but
we cannot sacrifice our ability to
update to some standard
not because that standard is best but
because we need some standard that we
can all
go to in order to exchange information
with each other
and for us to tear that apart inside of
the u.s so we don't even have a common
language anymore
is just so dangerous well and it's part
of what is being done with this
careful and often explicit renaming of
things in which words are
don't mean what they appear to mean and
hey zach you want to fix the screen
maybe i should deliberately watch
i don't know what you're going to say
that's the problem how about if you tell
me what you were going to say
and then we'll just sorry you just have
to be on screen that's fine
uh there we go um boy what are we
talking about
uh language yeah you need to have a
common standard yeah so you know
redefining racism out from under us
that robin d'angelo has has tried to do
and has managed to successfully
you know import to a lot of places is is
a way of guaranteeing that we don't have
uh communication between us and i do
wonder though
this is i i suspect we're coming up on
an hour and i have at least one more
thing that we want to talk about before
we
before we're done here um but maybe just
an asterisk for a later time
you've said this thing before about
feeling you know chagrined
not happy about it but you think that we
might all need one language in order to
talk and i
if so again just asterisk for a later
time
the sapir wharf hypothesis which posits
that the language you use shapes what
you
think and what actually you can think in
its strongest form
is generally not
agreed on by as far as i can tell almost
any linguist at this point
but a weak form of the sapir wharf
hypothesis
uh there seems to be a tremendous amount
of evidence for it actually that the
the language that you use actually
shapes how you think in your thought
patterns and this
this goes far beyond just word choice
it's also about you know syntax and
semantics
and i suspect although i haven't even
ever seen it in a discussion of saprio
wharf
for instance whether you have a uh
oh boy what are they an idiographic
versus a uh
oh alphabetic language i can't remember
the the words for it at this point but
whether or not you use an alphabet
or have effectively pictograms that that
you're using
um is going to shape is is going to
actually
shape how you think and i suspect
using an alphabet will tend towards
somewhat more reductive thinking
and less holistic thinking even within
alphabet using languages having subject
verb
object versus subject object verb may
have effects in terms of how you
prioritize and imagine
the hierarchy of objects and subjects in
the universe
so it will be a tough sell
and potentially destructive of cult some
cultures
to have uh to have there be a global
language and have
some languages disappeared yeah here's
the thing i would love
to live on that world where the cultures
aren't being destroyed
but like at the moment that everybody
got connected to the same internet
and is now subscribed to the same few
platforms yadda yadda on and on we
started doing this in earnest
and so the installation that these
cultures actually have from each other
is minimal and degrading over time
without a purpose
and so my point is actually we've got a
lot of stuff riding on the fact that we
don't have misunderstandings
that cause us to you know nuke each
other or invade each other and
so you know it's not without uh
reservation that i
say we would need a single language in
order to properly manage the affairs of
earth but i guess my point is
preserving the thing that would be
preserved by us not doing that
it's not happening we're losing that
thing and we're to lose it and then
we're
going to blow ourselves up because we
don't understand what
the people on the other side are saying
and that just seems an absurd waste to
me
yeah so maybe maybe we return to this uh
one more topic
uh we we had some stuff to talk about
with regard to cove at 19 but we'll save
that for another time
um but i wanted to bring up
uh this there's this there's a study
that was done many years ago
um that back in 2012 2013 was much
discussed
on the value of blind auditions
specifically
in the hiring of musicians for
orchestras
and christina hoff summers has done an
excellent takedown of the original study
in which she explains why it does not
actually
uh say what people were thinking it said
i i do not know exactly where that is
she does a femme splainer somewhere
on that um but uh we were basically told
that in order for
uh all the bias that existed in
orchestras specifically against women
uh to be solved there needed to be blind
auditions
uh that was published uh in the guardian
in 2013
zac if you want to show my screen yeah
so now in 2020
we have the new york times arguing that
to make orchestras more diverse we need
to end blind additions
uh because of course the addition
process being blind
uh means that not enough
people of diverse race gender and quote
unquote other factors
will be taken uh into effect um so
this is just this is the end of the
scientific process this is the end of
reason
this is the end of logic and everything
else
you can't have both ways you who are
arguing
that we need more diverse people in
orchestras you can't have it both ways
you can have it both ways that is
your white logic that says you can't
have it both ways
that is my use of the scientific method
also white
[Music]
i think we're done here yeah i mean no i
mean at some level
that's why we're fighting over this yes
because this is exactly logic
then none of this stands up if not logic
then anything goes and then it's all
about power which
yeah is an absurd place to want to want
to go no and also
i mean so that new york times article um
they don't even say sex
they say gender and um
which you know the original was
supposedly about sex and getting more
women in orchestras
uh and as christina hoff summers argued
it didn't actually work
anyway um but
again a conversation for another time
these categories that you can opt into
in the progressive stack that allow you
to basically game affirmative action
which is what's being argued for here
people are going to be opting into them
and we know they already
are right so trans is a particularly
obvious one
there are real trans people out there
and
they're very very rare and what we see
making such a ruckus and a
mess of things all over social media on
the streets and everywhere
are the trans rights activists who are
taking advantage of the fact that in
many places
you don't have to even be considering
surgery surgery or even hormones and
declare yourself trans all you have to
do is adopt some really regressive
gender norms put on a dress
put on some makeup call yourself a woman
and boom you're trans you get to rise in
a progressive stack
that's regressive and nasty and
disability is another one
because um we've had an explosion of so
many diagnoses and conditions
and many of them are invisible and
that means that really all someone would
have to do if they wanted to game the
system was declare themselves
disabled with some condition that no one
can see or perceive or is allowed to ask
about
and boom you've won yourself some more
oppression points so
uh gameable in every way all right
prediction
good the new york times will soon
embrace the idea not only
of removing blind auditions
but adding deaf auditions deaf auditions
for orchestras yeah for orchestras
exactly because
yeah all they want to see is a
demographic card
exactly auditions that are not deaf
discriminate against oppressed people
who do not play an instrument
am i right yeah i mean given that we're
suspending the laws of logic i think
it's as logical as anything
i am reminded of when we were in college
at uc santa cruz yeah in the early 90s
having there be a talk show host on the
campus radio station
who had a speech impediment that was so
intense
that he or she i don't honestly know
which could not make themselves
understood
to the people they were interviewing and
the people they're interviewing would
almost always have to
take the questions and after the person
interviewing them would read them
ask them themselves so that the people
listening could hear
this seemed like it had to be a parody
and this is a
long time ago but it was not a parody
and
i mean it's exactly what you're talking
about there are some jobs
that if you have a speech impediment you
should not have
not ideal and one of them is a job in
which the only thing you are projecting
into the universe is in fact your
your voice all right if you are
in fact incompetent as a musician you
should not
be playing in an orchestra i'd be like
go ahead cancel me
seriously all right so before we close
out here i just want to point out that
here and
we there was a good piece that reveals
the same thing
earlier this week which i guess we're
not going to show but um
here's the thing i know that the joke i
made
right accusing you as you invoked
science
and accusing you of using a white thing
in the context that science is
understood to be a positive thing
like as between two scientists saying
that it is a white thing is
deeply racist obviously that's why the
joke is funny
right if you are saying it in order to
neutralize
uh somebody's claim that something is
accurate in order to advance this woke
nonsense
then it is apparently anti-racist so the
very same claim
has both valences depending upon what
you're doing which is the height of your
logic
it's the natural endpoint of
post-modernism it is it we are
we are going to be uploaded to the
post-modern cloud
and we're going to borg yeah
it's a regrettable place for us to spend
the rest of our day as few as they may
be
okay on that happy note yeah no i was
hoping to have more hope
more hope yes um yes well
there's always the next live stream we
could try to
come up with some hope okay so you want
to say anything about unity 2020
before we go to the next
not right now well let's just say uh
stay
tuned to this channel um we have a big
upcoming
announcement we are working on tech to
make sure that the thing we are
announcing
will be firing on all cylinders of the
point we bring it to you all but i think
you're going to
enjoy it so stay tuned is the basic
message big things are happening yep
um next sunday at 11 a.m pacific
we will have our private q a for dark
horse members which you can become by
joining at my patreon
and you can join our the discord server
on either our patreons
uh and we have a clips channel that's
now live as well at dark horse clips
anything else anything else our course
podcast
we're changing that though oh well then
dark horse eclipse it is
um nope i think that's it um please
like subscribe comment distribute
disagree with um i don't know what else
don't set fire too yeah do not do not
incinerate
your cluster bombs out right and uh we
will see you in about 15 minutes
for the q a until then
you